all right so you also uh I watched the
Patrick David podcast a lot oh yeah me
too and you're the uh you do the theme
song yeah so how'd that happen yeah um
Patrick bad Dave is a big supporter man
so he's half Armenian half Assyrian and
he actually
um went to like high school with one of
my boys or whatever so years ago
um you know he was doing all these
videos on YouTube it was more like
um you know the business advice
motivation yeah that's pretty for his
podcast right that's what kind of blew
him up so my boy hit me like yo this guy
I used to know whatever like he's big
like check him out and we really started
watching these videos and actually it
was really dope you know what I'm saying
and then I started following him on IG
and [ __ ] and then one day he did a post
about hip-hop and he's like my top five
rappers of all time right and he's like
you know the regular night you know he's
in from the 90s probably he's like in
his mid-40s so he was like you know
Tupac Nas Jay-Z whatever and then in his
caption he wrote honorable mention my
man Armin is really dope you guys should
check him out and I'm like oh [ __ ] I
don't know no idea he knows me right
yeah and he even put the song like his
favorite song which was a song I did
with game a long time ago called Lost
Angels so you know then he followed me
back and everything and he was like yo
we support you we got you so he came by
my Store Pentagon when he was in LA then
when I went on tour with Berner
at that time he was in Texas he moved to
Florida I went over there to the
headquarters and then he came to the
show so he just really supportive you
know what I'm saying and then that's
when when we was in Texas he's like yo
maybe you can do like a song and we can
use it for like the YouTube videos at
the time it wasn't
um you know the podcast yet and I'm like
hell yeah I had this like kind of
motivational joint called Sweet Victory
and I sent it to him they loved it they
started using it for their interviews
first you know he did the interviews
like he has a crazy interview with Kobe
um yeah I've been watching him for like
five or six years so I've been watching
him when he was in Texas when he was
doing all the inspirational [ __ ]
interviewing people yeah same as same as
me so they used it just for their for
their uh interview section at that time
uh but a lot of big interviews Kevin
Hart Magic Johnson
even all the mobsters and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah I heard um Vlad say that he
got the idea from valuetainment which
was Patrick that day you know what I'm
saying
um so yeah and then and then you know
the interview thing kind of stopped and
then just recently
they started using the same song for the
podcast so and automatically I see a
boost in the streams you know what I'm
saying like it pops up on my top five
all of a sudden now it's dope to see
because like he's somebody and what's
also dope is like any kind of like
Middle Eastern conflict [ __ ] going on or
even like the Azerbaijan Armenia thing
he does like a full like I really
educated myself on what's going on I ran
or what's going on in Armenia when he
puts those videos up absolutely and just
like I learned a lot from watching his
[ __ ] just everything you know I mean
economy politics whatever like they you
know
it's like from all walks of political
absolutely the little white dude he's
with the comedian guys like more liberal
right you know what I mean yeah yeah
from all walks of life and they just
have like real honest discussions you
know what I mean yeah it's my man shout
out Patrick Bet David bro